you pose as a retail employee a lot and
and you as I said before people are
you're very good at making people
believe the product is real producing
them it's real yes in fact often times
it's harder to convince them that
they're on a show then that the product
isn't real right you know that will be
like you're on the TV shows like no way
and like well what's move easier to
believe the fact that that was really
pumping all that orange juice or that
you're on a show right just don't so we
have like show them the cameras
everything like that and then people
will they'll like you know say here you
know do put this on your show so I
bellick send us ideas like show one of
these real products so they said I
brought a letter to show you okay this
is from from a fan okay who clearly
doesn't understand that it's not real
okay and it would be funnier if you read
it I'm gonna read this I do not know
what this is it's from so John a sir
again thank you for your great for you
great show there's a little problem know
who you are and that most parts of the
show is fake would be happy to use the
sticker in your great show and then it
says your fend friend
so ang so Jonna surgeon right under
these stickers in here no so she sends
me stickers like use these stickers in
your show yeah what are you supposed to
do with these stickers those are like
the thing you've seen them that the at
the fair would they like curl up in your
oh you like a feel it okay yeah right so
appeal it it does like a refraction
okay so peel that right there then on
your pointer finger like this okay like
this alright okay and you should animate
it a little bit okay and if you put it
behind the glass you'll see it it'll
look like over here ya know flip it
there you're dealing with a muslin real
does it look real
yeah it kind of looks real yeah
you look like you would go like this
yeah like that if you touch it to the
water
[Applause]
it's like a refraction don't drink that
don't drink that don't drink
drinkable food no but the light makes it
look real incredible yeah it really does
but I wouldn't use it on the show
because that's like a real yeah very
nicely done you use magic in everyday
life realize what show he was on yeah
yeah he's the same hair yeah there's
nothing good you do you use magic in
everyday life to use it in situations
where like magic got me everything I
think I got it I got gonna NYU you know
I did a monologue I went for drama and
my grades were terrible but I showed
them a card trick at the audition and
they're like we should get him in there
clearly a wizard you can skip medical
school and perform operations
immediately hey thanks for watching
please subscribe to my youtube channel
so they will stop making me shoot these
videos please